[Music]
according to this second relationship
the believing consciousness partly has
its actuality in the real world of
culture and constitutes the spirit and
the existence of that world which we
have already considered partly however
the believing consciousness confronts
this its own actuality as something
worthless and is the process of
overcoming it this process does not
consist in the believing consciousness
making brilliant remarks about the
perversion of its real world for it is
the simple naive consciousness which
reckons such brilliance as vanity since
it still has the real world for its
purpose on the contrary contrasted with
the tranquil realm of its thought the
real world is a soulless existence which
therefore has to be overcome in an
external manner this obedience of
service and praise by setting aside
sense knowledge and action produces the
consciousness of unity with the absolute
being though not as a unity that is
actually perceived on the contrary this
service is only the perpetual process of
producing that unity a process which
does not completely attain its goal in
the present the religious community it
is true does so for it is universal
self-consciousness but for the
individual self consciousness the realm
of pure thought necessarily remains a
beyond of its actual world or sense this
beyond through the externalization of
the eternal being has entered the actual
world the actuality is an
uncomprehending sensuous actuality but
one sensuous actuality remains
indifferent to the other and the beyond
has only received the further character
of remoteness in space and time
the notion however the actuality of
spirit present to itself remains in the
consciousness of the believer the inner
being which is everything and which acts
but does not itself come forth
paragraph 534 is an interesting
departure from the sequence of short
paragraphs that preceded it and that are
going to follow it before we finish up
this section it's a little bit longer
there's a bit more going on here and
Hegel is explicitly telling us at the
beginning of this that we're looking at
the second what he calls the second
relationship this is referring back to
paragraph 530 where Hegel talked about
the three aspects so now we're actually
looking at how faith or the believing
consciousness stands in relationship
with the actual world in as Hegel had
said and antithesis to pure
consciousness
what is that pure consciousness going to
be so we're going to see now the world
of faith and you might say the practice
and the outcome of faith being spelled
out here in such a way but it's going to
lead to its opposite in the paragraphs
to come the opposite being pure insight
so he says the believing consciousness
partly has its actuality in the real
world of culture and this you know of
course is is trivially true
everybody has to exist in the real world
the actual world the world in which
there's possibility of being and the
question is can it escape that world or
is this whole business of faith going to
wind up coming back into this actual
world now from the point of view of the
believing consciousness there's
something wrong with the actual world
that's why it moved beyond the you know
jarring discordant world of culture in
which reason the rational self
consciousness had attempted to make some
sort of progress in understanding itself
and entertaining recognition how is this
going to pan out here so Hegel says it
has its actuality in the real world of
culture
and constitutes the spirit and the
existence of that world which we've
already considered now that could
actually be read two ways the world of
actual culture or the world of faith
consciousness is straddling both of
these we've seen that the world of faith
looks very attractive it's filled with
these spirits that are engaging in this
process of moving from substance to self
they're harmonious with each other
does this really satisfy self
consciousness the believing
consciousness so he says the believing
consciousness confronts this its own
actuality as something worthless and is
the process of overcoming it what does
Hegel mean there what is it
overcoming or transcending or subletting
is it its own consciousness itself as an
individual or is it also the actual
world that it finds its existence rooted
in and it's very praxis as a religious
believer rooted in as well well Hegel
tells us and he draws an interesting
contrast here says this process of
overcoming does not consist in the
believing consciousness making brilliant
remarks about the perversion of its real
world that's already been done remember
we had this this you know sophisticated
consciousness that was making those
sorts of remarks about how you know
screwed up the actual world was the
world that itself was rooted within and
didn't see a solution to and then Hegel
brings up again
the naive simple consciousness the you
know the person who's you know you might
say trying to bring it all back together
but it's still rooted within this actual
world and has not yet gone beyond to
faith or if they have it's not the faith
that we're
came out here this is very interesting
isn't it
Kierkegaard criticized Hegel for saying
that you know we begin with faith and
then then thinking happens after that
we've noticed now that Hegel when he
uses this term globine he says this is a
form of thought it's not just a naive
consciousness there has to have been an
alienation that has taken place I only
mentioned that in passing because it's
it's so often you know people take
Kierkegaard's criticism of Hegel which
is really more a criticism of Haig
aliens as determinative when all we have
to do is look within the text to find
out that there's more to the story than
that and perhaps there's some
possibility of connecting the two of
them together and perhaps not as you
know entirely on the same page but
departing from each other much later on
than at the start coming back to this so
he says this process does not consist in
the believing conscious is making
brilliant remarks about the perversion
of the real world it is the simple naive
consciousness which reckons such
brilliance as vanity since it still has
the real world for its purpose well
who's making those brilliant remarks
then the the skeptic the person who
remained within the the realm of culture
and didn't move on to faith or this
could in fact be the skeptic the
brilliant you know sophisticated
consciousness before it moves into faith
it might be somebody like Blaise Pascal
that Hegel has in mind here worth
considering now he goes on and he says
on the contrary so now we're talking
about the believing consciousness
contrasted with a tranquil realm of its
thought the real world is a soulless
existence it doesn't have value it
doesn't have real life to it why not
because something else has been
discovered that
is better than it that seems to be more
alive that seems to have greater meaning
to it more excitement more interest I'm
reminded here and this is a bit of a
digression of Chesterton's interesting
arguments made in his work orthodoxy and
I would say seconded in his father
Browns stories and some of his other
stories like the ball on the cross where
there's essentially an anesthetic not
aesthetic aesthetic argument being
developed in favor of religion in
general and perhaps we might say of
Christianity as it's perfect paradigm
although not perfectly revealed to us
and it runs like this the world is so
much more interesting when God is part
of it or beyond it's rather and this is
not you know a perfect argument that he
thinks is going to convince anybody but
it does get its hooks into some people
and I think that if you want to
understand what Hagel saying about the
believing consciousness at this point it
might be helpful to think in those terms
it's a more interesting world and a less
closed in claustrophobic crazy world the
one that has room for the absolute of
faith now Hegel goes on Tony says the
the real world is a soulless existence
it has to be overcome in an external
manner how is this done
notice what Hegel picks out here as the
praxis of faith of the believing
consciousness is it going out there and
doing deeds no is it building churches
is it teaching classes is it we might go
on and on and on and on Hegel says no
the obedience of service and praise
setting aside sense knowledge and action
the the stuff of the actual world of
culture produces the consciousness of
unity so we have a consciousness of
unity with the absolute being is there
really a unity here though how does any
amount of praise or service that we
iterate over and over again
actually cross us into the infinite
again we might think of Hegel and
Kierkegaard's criticisms of rationalism
and see that there's not that vast of a
difference between them an iterative
approximate of process never reaches its
end its Zeno's paradox
once again we can't attain the infinite
or the absolute in that way so he says
it doesn't produce this consciousness as
a unity that's actually perceived on the
contrary now this is a wonderful way of
framing it this service is only the
perpetual process of producing that
unity a process which is not completely
attained its goal in the present so we
might think here now let's make it more
concrete I'll think about the monks in
the desert engaging in prayer that's you
know both service and praise in in some
respect praying you know praising God
you know showing gratitude praying for
others confessing their sins and asking
for forgiveness all of that produces a
consciousness of unity but it's not one
that remains entirely after the act is
finished and it's not one that attains
its goal while the act is going on so
when does this unity actually occur
Hegel says it's not perceived as such
but it is cognized as such notice the
language that he's using here he's not
saying oh you feel this this unity or
something like that this is not a faith
of you know the affections faith is a
mode of thought for Hegel how is it
actually attaining its object so he goes
on and he says on the contrary right
this doesn't attain its goal in the
presence now notice what he says about
the religious community the religious
community does so does attain its goal
in the present does produce that unity
why because the religious community as
opposed to the believing individual is a
universal right but we want to think
about well what kind of universal is
this here is this a universal that is
being thought as such a kind of ideal
universal a figment of one's imagination
we might say because it's really just a
bunch of monks out there in the desert
or it's a bunch of you know people
singing together in a church or it's a
bunch of people offering incense and
meditating together or what what it what
is this religious community Hegel
doesn't go any further with that here
does he he just kind of throws that out
here that the religious community does
attain through service and praise with
the believing consciousness is
attempting but failing to achieve but
does that help thee believe in
consciousness says for the individual
self consciousness the realm of pure
thought
now notice necessarily remains a beyond
of its actual world it is still rooted
in its actual world but isn't the
religious community also rooted in the
actual world insofar as every member of
it and indeed it's its
resistance its its presence it doesn't
that have to be rooted in the actual
world I would say yes so he says the the
realm of your thought remains a beyond
of its a actual realm actual world or it
says or sense this beyond through the
external ization of eternal being has
entered the actual world the actuality
is a nun comprehended sensuous actuality
then he goes on and says but one
sensuous actuality remains indifferent
to the other and the beyond has only
received the further character of
remoteness in space in time so the more
that we make the absolute being
something that we can grasp something
that we can visualize something that we
can relate ourselves to say as a statue
or as a shrine or something along those
lines the more we lose sight of what it
was that we were attempting to attain
this is something that Hegel thinks is
not just about some far off beyond out
there but the beyond that thought itself
is projecting from itself you you might
say let me say that one more time since
that might go might sound a little bit
strange it is a beyond that thought is
projecting within thought for itself as
thought but not fully recognizing as
such so he says the notion the actuality
of spirit present to itself remains in
the consciousness of the believer the
inner being which is everything and
which acts but does not come forth what
is he talking about there well in the
next paragraph we see I'm talking about
pure insight so now we're going to see a
movement back from this absolute being
to the consciousness is that the
believing consciousness it's at going to
recognize something about all of this
that's been going on up to this point
and make the transition into pure
insight
in pure insight however the notion is
alone the actual and this third aspect
of faith that of being an object for
pure insight is really the true relation
in which faith here appears pure insight
itself like faith is to be considered
partly in and for itself and partly in
its relation to the actual world so far
as this is still present in a positive
form that is as a vane consciousness and
lastly in that relation to faith
mentioned above
with paragraph 535 we're now back to
these very short paragraphs and Hegel
here begins now talking about pure
insight in its own right as something
that is coming out of faith or rather is
developing we might say from the
believing consciousness in a certain
sense surpassing itself so he says in
pure insight the notion is alone the
actual so transformation is taking place
here the the concept the notion is the
actual is what is present for us and
pure insight is going to be taking this
critical attitude towards the world of
faith the world of the supersensible
beyond and so he says this third aspect
of faith that of being an object for
pure insight the third aspect was its
relation to the other two its other
right so faith is the other for insight
but insight how is insight the other two
faith it is the other two faith by by
making faith into its object the object
of critical analysis the object of
critical study looking at it through a
different lens remember that earlier
Hegel had said that that in a certain
sense the consciousness of faith was
lacking self consciousness and the
consciousness of pure insight really
that's all it had was with self
consciousness so this is a very
important transition point he says this
third aspect of faith that of being an
object for pure insight is really the
true relation in which faith here
appears so this doesn't mean that every
person who has faith is going to grasp
this as a matter of fact you might say
that for Hegel faith
if it's followed through to its full
extent is going to reveal itself as
insufficient in relation to the pure
insight that is reflecting on that faith
hasn't always been like that I mean we
might think of some of the great
medieval thinkers talking about the the
relation between faith and let's call it
reason right or pure insight you know we
might think of an sums you know faith
seeking understanding and some is a
great believer I understand the pun
there completely great believer in
seeing faith as something that is to be
understood not just rested there in
faith and he says at certain points you
know like if scripture seems to be
saying things that don't make any sense
well there must be something wrong with
our reading of Scripture we need to read
it so that it actually does in some
sense accord with right reason and he's
taking that as a touchstone now Ansem
gets accused of everything from being a
fee deist at one extreme to being a
rationalist of being incoherent in the
middle or to having a great synthesis ha
them both and we might use other
examples as well coming back to Hegel he
says pure insight itself like faith is
to be considered partly in and for
itself that was that first aspect right
partly in its relationship to the actual
world so far as this is still present in
a positive form how is the actual world
present in a positive form well faith
had seen it as something that was a vain
consciousness and so had culture at the
end and lastly in that relation to faith
mentioned above
so Hegel is now laying out for us these
three different distinct movements
saying that now pure insight has to have
that and the entire movement has shifted
from faith to pure inside will pure
insight be able to liberate itself
entirely from faith that's a open
question
is there an asymmetry between them
clearly there's an asymmetry even though
Hegel has introduced this parallelism of
these three moments because you notice
we're going to move into pure insight
and does that mean that we're going to
completely leave faith behind good
question
we have seen what pure insight is in and
for itself as faith is the tranquil pure
consciousness of spirit as essence so is
pure insight the self-consciousness of
spirit as essence it therefore knows
essence not as essence but is absolute
self if therefore seeks to abolish every
kind of independence other than that of
self consciousness whether it be the
independence of what is actual or of
what possesses intrinsic being and to
give it the form of notion pure insight
is not only the certainty of self
conscious reason that it is all truth it
knows that it is
paragraph 536 has almost a triumphal
kind of heir to a driving ahead telling
us exactly what pure insight is in and
for itself we do have to remember of
course before we go into this and and
look at how wonderful what's being
achieved is and how powerful pure
insight is that there are three aspects
right so what it is in and for itself is
the first of them what it is in relation
to the actual world which which right
now it seems to be getting the better of
the actual world that's going to be the
second and then its relation to its
opposite or correlative faith is gonna
be the third so let's stick with this
this you know first one he says we've
seen what pure insight is it in for
itself as faith is the tranquil pure
consciousness of spirit as essence so is
pure insight self-consciousness of
spirit as essence self consciousness not
just consciousness not just setting it
as an object over there a beyond
something that is different than the
conscious being self consciousness that
is me I am that spirit that is essence
Hegel goes on a little bit further he
says it is the air for knows essence not
as essence not just as a being but as
absolute self this is very interesting
isn't it when we realize our own
critical capacities when we truly
realize them not just in the process of
knocking things down or taking easy
shots but the scope that they have what
it is that pure insight can actually do
if we're self conscious of that at this
point we're now realizing that that
Devine that absolute is not something
separate from me
that I have to worship through praise
and service that is me I'm in there
somehow and now notice what he talks
about the independence of everything
else has to be as he says overcome or
abolished seeks to abolish every kind of
independence other than that of
self-consciousness whether it be the
independence of what is actual the
actual world or what possesses intrinsic
being what is on Zeke and to give it the
form of notion so it doesn't a Polish it
entirely
it doesn't just do a skeptical I don't
believe the world is there rather it
gives it the form of notion of concept
of be Griff it makes it into its own
object of thoughts who do you think
Hagel has in mind here does this sound
it all say like the movement going on in
dick Hart it should it might also if you
read the first parts of Leviathan even
though Hobbes is you know of course a
mechanist definitely not talking about
spirit other than a material thing might
also you might also think about what
Hobbes is doing in his attempt to you
know reformulating a science at last not
just a for civil society but of
everything self-consciousness reduces
everything in the actual world to the
notion that it can make of it we might
also think about Locke perhaps there's a
false humility in saying that he's a
mere you know clearing away of the
clutter person so that you know real
epistemology can take place maybe Locke
is doing this as well this is worth
considering now he says
self-consciousness attempts to abolish
every kind of indepen
other than of its own pure insight he
says is not only the certainty of self
conscious reason that it is all truth
where did we encounter that at the
beginning of the reason section right
now we're in the spirit section so self
conscious
he says peer insight is not only the
certainty of self conscious reason that
it is all truth it knows that it is it
has knowledge it is able to cognize
everything being there for it so this is
a very important transition point isn't
it pure insight abrogates to itself the
right to criticize everything to make
everything into an object for it to come
up with a theory of everything this is a
very different compartment than the
faith that we've just looked at in the
paragraphs previous to this in this
section
you